[MUSIC PLAYING]
CLIFF REDEKER: Good
afternoon, and to the folks
who are joining us on
our internal live stream,
also welcome.
We're very keen on having
members of the San Francisco
Opera here with us today.
They'll be discussing their
world premiere of "Two Women."
To kick things off, we do
have Kip Cranna, the dramaturg
of the San Francisco Opera.
And he'll be leading this
moderated discussion.
So, please join me in
welcoming them to Google.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
KIP CRANNA: Thank you, Cliff,
and thanks to Google for
inviting us.
We're thrilled to be
down here to tell you
about this exciting
opera, "La Ciociara."
Let me introduce the
people who are involved
so centrally in creating it.
And I'll just go
down the row here.
Next to me is the
script writer, which
is sort of an unusual
thing for an opera to have.
And we'll talk about that.
He is an Italian author, and has
had a career as a journalist,
and is now a screenplay
writer, scriptwriter,
for Italian cinema and TV.
Luca Rossi.
Thank you, Luca, for being here.
LUCA ROSSI: Hello.
[APPLAUSE]
KIP CRANNA: And next
to him, of course,
is the important figure
of all in putting
on a new opera, our
composer, who has
composed more than 16 operas.
He's one of Italy's most
preeminent composers
of the day.
And we're so thrilled
to be working with him.
Marco Tutino.
[APPLAUSE]
KIP CRANNA: And in the middle,
the guy whose fault this
all is.
It's his idea to do an Italian
opera, and we're doing one.
He's our Music Director
at San Francisco Opera,
and the conductor of this opera.
And we're so
thrilled that he has
gotten us to do this project.
It's been a great challenge
for a San Francisco opera.
Nicola Luisotti.
[APPLAUSE]
KIP CRANNA: And then we
have one of the two women
that this opera is about.
She sings the role of
Rosetta, the young girl who
goes out into the countryside
with her mother during World
War II, and faces all kinds
of trials and tribulations.
She had a wonderful debut
with us on Saturday night.
Sarah Shafer.
[APPLAUSE]
KIP CRANNA: And then
we have the tenor,
who, of course, is the hero.
The hero is always a tenor in
Italian operas-- almost always.
And he had a great
success singing
the role of Michele, who
is our idealistic hero
in this story who,
unfortunately, meets a sad end.
But then again, it's
opera, so what can you do?
He's the Greek-American
tenor Dimitri Pittas.
[APPLAUSE]
KIP CRANNA: And, Nicola,
let's start with you,
because this whole
idea started with you.
Where did the idea
come from to commission
an Italian opera
from Marco Tutino?
NICOLA LUISOTTI: I think
that the San Francisco
Opera has Italian roots
with Gaetano Merola, that
was music director of this
company in [INAUDIBLE], right?
KIP CRANNA: Yes, he
founded the company
in the late '20s--
early '20s, rather.
NICOLA LUISOTTI: And I
think that an Italian opera
with an Italian music director
needs a new Italian opera to be
performed for the first time.
If we go in the past, in the
United States, the last opera
that was performed in the United
States for the first time,
was Il Trittico by Giacomo
Puccini, it was 1918.
After 97 years, finally we
have another Italian opera
with a great composer, with
an Italian great composer
that is Marco Tutino.
I'm very honored to have done
this opera for first time here,
for the history of Italy,
but for the history also--
the mutual history of
the United States .
KIP CRANNA: Now, had you
worked with Marco before this?
NICOLA LUISOTTI: I work
in for some things,
and I have conducted in
Napa Valley in 2007 music
from a ballet from Richard III.
It was pretty beautiful
music, and if we can still
use this word, it
was beautiful music.
I'm proud to say that,
because in the past decades,
we used to shock people
instead to do delight them.
So, I think that
with La Ciociara,
we delighted all
the audience also,
even if this is a great drama.
But inside of this music,
there are beautiful lines
that people will
remember for their life.
And this will save Marco
Tutino and his own music.
KIP CRANNA: Marco,
what did you think
when you were asked to write an
opera for an American company?
Was this the first
time you had done that?
MARCO TUTINO: Yes, an
opera, yes, the first time.
Well, I don't know if I am a
great composer as Nicola told--
NICOLA LUISOTTI: You are.
MARCO TUTINO: I think that we
have to wait at least 100 years
to know exactly.
But this is right for
all the kind of arts.
We have a lot of rush to
decide oh, yes, no, yes, no.
I thought to my job in
a very concrete way.
Because I think that-- solid
way, because the opera composer
is a specialized
composer, who has
to face a lot of
dramaturgical problems.
And you must do as
well as you know.
And I think that I
accepted this job
with the knowledge
of the difficulties,
and the knowledge
of a new public.
But I was very, very confident
about the professionalilty
of this theater.
And the show was
absolutely perfect.
All of the theater
worked so hard.
And of course, I based
my hope in Nicola.
Because I knew which kind
of conductor he actually is.
KIP CRANNA: We should talk about
this choice of subject matter.
Where did that idea come from,
to use La Ciociara, the novel,
as a source for your opera?
NICOLA LUISOTTI: La
Ciociara because a night
at a dinner with Marco
and [INAUDIBLE], he's
a friend of ours, and is a great
actor and a great director.
We were talking about how
will be possible to renew
the repertoire.
You know, the problem
with the opera today
is that the repertoire is stuck.
When we finished with
Puccini, La Turandot in 1926,
then something happened.
Curiosities-- the
new composers since
didn't find the
right way to proceed
from the roots of their fathers,
composers like Wagner, Strauss,
Mozart, Verdi, Donizetti,
Bellini, Weber, or whatever.
At some point we have-- after
the second school of Vienna,
that is Schoenberg,
Berg, and Webern,
they did fantastic things
in the middle of two wars.
The first global war,
the second global war.
Since then, something happened.
What's happened?
The people think
that the catastrophe
was close to happen.
The world, for sure, after
the second world war,
were going to finish in
an atomic nuclear war,
were close to come.
In the '60s, we really
were scared about this.
And all the music was talking
to us about catastrophes.
Every year, this
is going to happen.
This is going to happen.
And nothing happened like that.
But still, we believe
in these kind of music
that the world is destroyed.
It is not.
There are many
problems in the world,
but there's also people
that believe in the future--
throughout the past,
throughout the present,
throughout the future.
And at some point, we
have to change our line.
Because we are losing an
important presence in theater.
Who pay the tickets?
It's very simple.
Critics, they don't pay
tickets, for example.
They receive credits.
It's true.
So, the audience
pay the tickets.
And why they have to pay $300
to listen to something that they
will never understand.
Why?
I would like not to
pay something, so
many moneys for something
that I will never understand.
I would prefer to
go to the movie.
I will go to the musical.
If you take a look, for
example, in New York.
Metropolitan Opera House is
struggling to sell tickets.
Struggling.
But there are more than
30 theaters of musicals.
More than 30, every
night full of people.
KIP CRANNA: On Broadway.
NICOLA LUISOTTI: We have to
speak with ourself about that.
So, La Ciociara-- I'm coming.
[LAUGHTER]
NICOLA LUISOTTI: La Ciociara
is done because we want back
the audience.
It's wrong?
I don't know.
But we try to-- I mean,
Marco Tutino tried
to compose something that was
beautiful for the history,
for the people, for
the musicians to play,
for me to conduct,
for-- I mean he
has written an opera in
an Italian tradition.
I don't think this is a mistake.
But this is challenge
to this today.
KIP CRANNA: Well, this brings
us to the story itself,
La Ciociara, a novel by Alberto
Moravia; published, I believe,
in 1957.
Made, of course, into
the famous film in 1960,
directed by Vittorio De
Sica, starring Sophia Loren,
who won the Academy Award.
First time that award
had gone to an actor
in a non-English speaking role.
Very exciting.
Luca, tell us your story
about getting the rights
to this novel, which
was not an easy thing.
LUCA ROSSI: Well,
that was just--
the beginning of
the story was nice,
because we were with Marco
in a small trattoria in Rome.
And he had Nicola and
his idea of La Ciociara.
And there was the
problem of the rights,
because they belonged
to the family, the two
women, actually, the
two widows of Moravia.
KIP CRANNA: Moravia
has two widows.
Both within [INAUDIBLE].
LUCA ROSSI: And we just saw
one of these two widows, Carmen
Llera, getting in a house,
in a door of a palace there.
And so we thought, why don't we
leave a letter to the doorman?
And we start the thing.
And the real story
started from there.
Then we had a lot of troubles
with the second widow,
but that's not so important.
But--
KIP CRANNA: She
agreed eventually,
that's what's important.
LUCA ROSSI: In the end, yes.
But what I would like to say
is that, it was very important.
Marco's music is
a narrative music.
It has a narration in it.
We know what
contemporary music did.
They deconstructed
the structure.
Marco has a structure
but to have that,
you have also to
have a narrative
structure inside the opera.
So La Ciociara is a wonderful
book, a wonderful movie.
But it lacks a
lot of, let's say,
twists, a lot of
important moments.
And it lacks a real love story.
It lacks the usual
things that you'd
find in movies, in
fiction, and so forth.
So that was my role,
Marco asking me,
since that's what-- I'm a
writer and a screenwriter.
So I know, in some way, the
twists, how to build a story.
So we had to invent a
part of the story, based,
of course, on La Ciociara.
And we invented Giovanni, which
in the book and in the movie
is a very minor character, he
developed into the villain.
But still, there,
since there is,
again-- I want to stress this.
There is a narrative
in the music of Marco.
And that's avant
garde to my eyes now.
Because after we
deconstructed music,
now we have to build music.
So in this way, this narrative
of the music, in some way,
it's intermingled with the
narrative of the story.
That I think it's a very simple
story under many perspectives.
It's simple because
it's a melodrama.
We can't have too many nuances.
But still, it has a
dignity as a story,
and I could see
it in the public,
in the audience in the
night of the premiere,
they were really
following the story.
And there was a sort of
suspense in some moments.
You really don't know
how it's going to end.
I think this was a very
nice success for all of us.
And I think that
this is the path
modern music should pursue.
The fact you're telling
a story to people
also through the music.
You are making the
narrative, which
is what human beings do
since their beginnings.
They always tell stories.
And I think La Ciociara
is a wonderful story.
Thank you.
KIP CRANNA: We want to
hear from our singers,
but before we do that,
I think that it would
be useful to watch
a little clip that
talks about the kind of
central element in the drama.
Most Americans, I think,
learn about World War
II in some detail, but not about
the war in Italy, which is,
of course, what
this opera is about,
as is the film and the novel.
And it deals, of course,
with the end of the war,
after Mussolini has
been put in prison.
The Germans have occupied Italy.
The Allies are trying
to get to Rome.
They invade at Anzio.
There's a landing there.
There's a famous battle
of Monte Cassino, which
was essential in
breaking through what
was called the Gustav Line,
the Germans' defensive line,
protecting the north of Italy.
And very central in
winning this battle,
were some 8,000 Moroccan troops,
French-speaking Moroccan troops
called Goumiers.
And we're going to watch
a little clip of a video
that's on YouTube, if
you just Google Goumiers,
G-O-U-M-I-E-R-S, you'll see
this longer documentary.
But we're just going to watch
a few seconds of it, which
talks about how, once these
troops had won their battle,
ran wild, and raped and
pillaged, quite literally.
And this is part of
an interview with some
of the victims of this tragedy.
KIP CRANNA: So, I have
to tell you the story,
since I work with
commissioning new operas.
When we saw the first draft
of the scenario from Luca,
we thought, violence
from Africans,
and we were worried about
political correctness.
And we said, couldn't-- do
they have to be Africans?
Could they be Germans, maybe?
Australians?
Who knows.
Not knowing, as Americans
don't know, the central role
that this tragedy had
in Italian sensibility
and Italian memories of the war.
And so this is, of
course, a central scene.
And that brings
us to you, Sarah,
because you are one of
the-- your character
is one of the women
victimized by these characters
in the opera.
And you have a
great transformation
to go through from an innocent
16-year-old girl to the girl
that survives all this.
Do you want to talk about
how you pull that off,
dramatically and vocally?
SARAH SHAFER: Sure.
It's definitely a
big transformation
that the character of
Rosetta goes through.
She starts the opera
very shy, and very
obedient to her mother,
quite a good girl.
Very religious.
And you see, in the
second act, when
bombs start to go
off, that she turns
right to religion, which shows
a lot about her character.
And then as the opera
goes on, all these things
start to happen to her.
And Michele gets arrested.
And they become alone,
and then they're attacked.
And there's a huge change
that goes on after the rape.
She's completely traumatized.
And it sort of flips her
character 180, on her head.
And she rebels, and all
this change happens.
And she, you know, looks for
affection not from her mother,
but from men.
And so it's maybe the
most difficult acting role
that I've had to play,
so far, in my career--
which I'm very
early in my career.
But it's definitely-- I mean,
it's so much of an acting role.
She's on stage a lot.
And the singing that
Marco writes for Rosetta
is completely indicative of what
her character is going through
at that particular moment.
So it's very-- in a
way, it's very natural
to play the evening.
Because you feel what's
happening right up to-- you
don't have to put on anything
to play this character.
What happens is right
there for you in the music.
KIP CRANNA: Now, you're
playing opposite Anna Caterina
Antonacci, one of the premier
Italian artists in the world
today, and a legendary
stage animal actress.
And she's also, simultaneously,
doing the role of Cassandra
in Berlioz's The Trojans here.
So she's quite busy.
Tell us about working
with her and creating
this onstage relationship.
SARAH SHAFER: It was wonderful.
She's very-- it was very
intimidating at first,
because I had never seen acting
like that in opera before.
And I didn't know quite
what to make of it.
But I learned so much from
just watching her, you know.
And it helped my own acting.
And I kind of
found a place where
I could sort of work with
her, and sort of imitate
and copy some of
the things that she
was doing to make them seem
like they're related, you know.
But she can just stand on
stage completely still,
and it's so moving.
You can be so still in
the things that you act.
And so it was a huge learning
experience for me, singing
and just being with her.
I think it's grown me a lot as a
singer, and as an actress, too.
KIP CRANNA: I would have to
say, just as an audience member,
she is the kind of artist
you can't take your eyes off.
It's just--
SARAH SHAFER: Stunning.
She's beautiful.
KIP CRANNA: So, Dimitri,
you're the love interest.
[LAUGHTER]
KIP CRANNA: And you have
a transformation as well,
going from a kind of a
bookish, shy professor,
to a genuine hero, who
does a great sacrifice
for the sake of love.
Talk about that
characterization.
DIMITRI PITTAS: Sure.
Yes, it's true, there is
a big journey that goes on
with Michele, even
though he's not
on from the beginning
of the opera,
and he's certainly not towards
the end of the opera, either.
But these two women
come into his life
and affect him in such a way.
And the journey is
unique, I think,
to a lot of tenor
repertoire, it's true.
But it's also-- I love it.
I think that it makes a lot of
sense within this story, also.
Particularly because
of the relationships
that Marco has
managed to maintain
between all of the characters.
And it really is a pleasure.
What he decides, and that
definitive moment when
he sacrifices everything for the
sake of the lives of these two
women, it's very strong.
It's very poignant to
me on stage every night.
And also, it's a
part of the show
that I just can't get
out of my head musically.
I just keep on hearing it
over and over and over,
which is testament to
wonderfully written opera
as well.
So I enjoy going through
that journey every night
that we do it.
KIP CRANNA: And there's
quite a vital scene
toward the end-- we've
already mentioned
what happens to the women.
And more-or-less
simultaneously, you're
being prepared to be
executed for treason,
having saved, helped
an American soldier,
and the Nazis have arrested
you for doing that.
So this all happens
more-or-less simultaneously,
in alternation, really, with
the scene with the women.
Can you talk about
how you pull that
off emotionally, dramatically?
DIMITRI PITTAS: Yeah, sure.
It is-- the way Marco put it
together is really stunning.
It's almost as if you can
imagine this split stage,
where these two really
shocking incidents
are happening at the same time.
And when we first started
putting it together,
we actually tried
to-- I tried to watch
what was happening on the
other side of the stage,
just because it fed me.
And it fed my emotions.
Because even though Michele is
going through something really
terrible, to know that the
people that he cares most about
are going through
something that is
infinitely more difficult than
what's about to happen to him.
It really feeds my reason
for what I have done,
and the decision that I've made.
And musically, it's just very
clear, it's very splendid.
And it's the highlight of
the evening, I think, also.
And the production
is fantastic, too,
the way that it cuts
that scene so perfectly,
but it blends them together
in such an amazing way.
It's really something to
be a part of every night.
KIP CRANNA: I'm curious
how the decision came
to do it this way.
Luca, did this
idea come from you,
to do these two
scenes in alternation,
rather than just doing
one whole scene--
LUCA ROSSI: We were together,
me and Marco, I remember.
I think I'm right, Marco, no?
We decided, since the
opera is so crowded
with facts-- it's a real
story, like a fiction.
So there are a lot
of things going on.
KIP CRANNA: There's
a lot of action.
LUCA ROSSI: And in that
moment, the problem was that.
As Dimitri said, this
is the highlight.
But we have two highlights.
The one is the death
of the good guy.
The other is the rape.
So it's very difficult,
which when you put first?
If you put first
one, the other is
going to be lessened--
destroyed in some way.
So the idea was to put them
together in the same moment,
so you can switch from one to
the other with the same kind
of tension that
grows, grows, grows,
and then it collapses
when the thing is over.
I think that Francesca
did a very-- Francesca
Zambello, the director, did
a very good job in freezing
those moments, so
you-- with the lights,
and the freezing of the actors.
You are even more into
the tension of the scene.
And then what's even more
interesting, I think,
is that after this, you
have a whole other scene.
I mean, in a normal opera,
this is the end of the opera.
The guy is dead, women raped.
OK, goodbye.
KIP CRANNA: [INAUDIBLE]
kills herself [INAUDIBLE].
LUCA ROSSI: No, there
is a whole new field.
That's what makes people,
I think, really curious.
Because, what happens now?
I mean, the story's finished.
No, it is not finished.
It starts here, again.
So I think it's
really the turning
point of the story
is that moment,
and was beautifully done.
KIP CRANNA: I'm glad
you touched on that.
So this isn't a story
about two tragedies,
and the curtain comes in.
There is another story about
reconciliation, and about hope,
and about remembered
love that gives people
the strength to go forward.
Sarah, talk a little bit
about that, would you?
About how this
scene works for you,
as you come out of
the sort of trance
you've been in
following the violence.
And we're not sure
exactly what happens next,
but we get an idea.
SARAH SHAFER: Yes, the last
scene is a huge one for me,
in terms of character.
You know, she goes
into this-- at least
from Rosetta's point of view,
she is away from her mother.
And she doesn't speak to her.
She doesn't acknowledge her.
The rest of the town is
joyous, because the Americans
have come, and so you're back in
this seeming triumphant scene.
But having seen
the previous scene,
there's a strange
feeling about it.
Because, oh, this
has just happened,
and how can the world go on
when this event has happened?
KIP CRANNA: She
blames her mother--
SARAH SHAFER: She
blames her mother.
She blames-- I think,
she also blames herself,
but she won't admit it.
You know there's-- she blames
herself for Michele's arrest.
And there's all of Michele
also in the back of her mind.
And then, of course,
throughout the scene,
we find out that
Giovanni comes in,
and find we've found out
that Michele is dead.
And then Cesira relates that
to Rosetta, which kind of
brings her back to herself.
And you kind of see the collapse
of her put-on rebellion.
It's not really who she is.
It's just become this
wall that she doesn't
want people to see her anymore.
But that all comes down
with the information
that Michele is dead.
And so then she has no one.
She has not a wall, she
doesn't have Michele.
Rosetta has sort of
this crush on Michele,
I think, through
the whole thing.
And so with all that gone,
she turns again to her mother.
And there's this
beautiful reconciliation
at the end, which you don't get
in the book, or in the movie.
And it brings such hope, as you
say, to the end of the piece.
And, you know, the
music that Marco writes
is so amazing at the end.
And you sense that they're
off on a new adventure.
Not in the same way that
they have been in Act One,
but that they
actually are two women
having gone through
something together,
starting anew and going
on with their lives.
So it's very beautiful.
LUCA ROSSI: May I add?
KIP CRANNA: Yes, please.
LUCA ROSSI: It's true.
What's very important
is that in the finale,
the reconciliation
is the heritage,
is Michele's heritage.
And in fact, we see
Michele in the back.
But--
KIP CRANNA: Like
a vision of him.
LUCA ROSSI: It's--
he left something.
When they say, when
the opera is finished,
they say nothing is left.
No.
Something is left, is
the heritage of Michele.
If we want to say in common
words, it's goodwill.
To be good.
To try to think that the world
is not only of smart asses,
but is also of the good ones.
And in the last scene, as we
designed it in the beginning,
then there were problems
for the production.
But there were a group of kids
playing war in the last scene,
in the very last moment.
And one of these little
kids fell and hurt himself.
And the ghost of
Michele was passing by,
was helping this little
kid, and bringing him away,
off the stage.
And that was the meaning.
The good there is in Michele
saves also Cesira and Rosetta,
that they get together again.
So that's, I think, it's
a very profound message.
And maybe we have to work
for the next production
to make it more clear.
But I think it was enough clear.
KIP CRANNA: You mentioned
in the next production.
We know that this
production will
be performed in Torino in 2018.
And, we hope, other
places as well.
There's a metaphor of
a flower associated
with the memory of
Michele, also associated
with the love of
Michele and Cesira.
Was that your idea?
Where did that come from?
LUCA ROSSI: Well, actually,
I found the botanical.
I was looking on the
internet, because we
wanted a flower,
something that could
be in winter in Ciociaria.
It was very difficult. There is
nothing in winter in Ciociaria.
But in the end, I came
out with this fiammella,
we call it in Italian.
What's the name,
the botanical name?
You wrote it.
NICOLA LUISOTTI:
Clematis flammula.
KIP CRANNA: For you
botanists in the audience.
LUCA ROSSI: And, by
chance, I discovered
this thing, in some
cases, can flourish also
in the late winter.
So the idea was perfect.
It's called fiammella, that
means "little fire" in Italian.
So it's perfect
for a love scene.
Nothing better.
KIP CRANNA: And this
is an idea that's
not in either the
book or the film,
but is especially for the opera.
We're going to give people
a chance to ask questions.
And I'm sure all you
Google people know to go
to the microphone to do that.
Let me ask one more
question before we do that.
Marco, we have many sort of
traditional Italian, Roman
tunes, or poems,
included in the opera.
And particularly an Italian
popular song from World War II.
Can you talk about the
decision to use that?
MARCO TUTINO: Well,
this popular song
was used also by
in De Sica when he
did the movie,
because the song was
a symbol of the end
of the war in Italy.
Every people, everybody sang
this song on the street,
on the radio.
It was very, very popular.
I think that it
could be a good idea
to use this theme
for-- of course,
to use the old songs at the end.
But to use in a certain ways
little pieces, little portion
of the song, and
made them floating
in the score for
all of the opera,
for all the duration
of the opera.
So when you hear at
the end the music,
the original music of this
song in a certain way, and you
recognize it.
And you don't know why.
LUCA ROSSI: And no
critic understood this.
Not one single one, who said,
oh, there is "La Strada del
Bosco" everywhere.
No one.
Just to tell you guys.
MARCO TUTINO: It's
too difficult.
KIP CRANNA: Do we have
any questions out there?
Cliff, do you have questions
for our Google people?
CLIFF REDEKER: I guess we can
start out just by talking,
as you look at the Opera
season calendar and the season
subscription, what
responsibility do
you have to continue
pushing the envelope forward
with new compositions,
such as these?
How do you balance that with
folks that want to harken back
to the turn-of-the-century
Italian operas?
And how do you
approach that balance?
KIP CRANNA: And, Nicola,
can you talk about that?
When we choose the seasons, what
operas we're going to be doing,
popular ones, unusual
ones, not popular ones.
NICOLA LUISOTTI: I think David
Gockley is to be the best guy--
KIP CRANNA: Our General
Director, David Gockley.
NICOLA LUISOTTI: Our
General Director.
I think that, when
we do a season,
we have to balance between what
it was, what it's going to be,
what will be.
And in this particular
season, in the season of '15,
we have three
story, three operas,
that talk about two women.
Because we have
in "Les Troyens,"
we have two women,
Cassandra and Dido.
In "Nozze di Figaro," we
have two women, Countess
and Susanna.
And in Two Women,
we have two women.
So-- Cesira, Rosetta.
And all the three operas
are speaking about war.
Because if you
think-- the civil war.
If you think that we have
the war in the, of course,
in the classic period
with "Les Troyens."
We have very close
the French Revolution
in "Nozze di Figaro."
And we are in the middle
of the second global war,
and the civil war also in
Italy during the second war.
So I think that the
choice is-- all the operas
we are doing this season are
very well connected, and very
well balanced between classic,
romantic and modern one.
So, this is how--
KIP CRANNA: It is a good example
of this delicate balancing
act of the 10 operas we do in
the year, three of them come
at this period in the summer.
And we have something
very familiar,
"The Marriage of Figaro."
We have something
unusual, rarely done,
it's been over 40 years since
we've done "The Trojans,"
because it's so immense.
And then something brand-new.
So it's important to
have things to appeal
to a wide variety of audiences.
Is there another
question out there?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
First, thank you for
coming to talk to us.
This is very interesting.
So, my question is
related to the fact
that La Ciociara is also a
very famous movie by De Sica,
and Sophia Loren, and I think
it got one or two Oscars.
And Maestro Luisotti was talking
about the ticket-buying public.
From observation, I guess,
that a lot of the people coming
to San Francisco
probably went on a date
to see in the '60s La Ciociara.
So, no doubt this
is in their minds,
and kind of invites
some comparison,
it seems, as the
opera follows the book
less closely than the movie.
But I'm curious how
the movie influenced
your singing, your development.
I mean, the fact that you know
that people will no doubt will
have the movie in the back
of their mind, a lot of them?
KIP CRANNA: Thank you
for that question.
We should clarify,
just to be sure,
that the opera is officially
based on the book, not
the movie.
But how did the movie influence
the development of the opera?
LUCA ROSSI: Well, I
don't know for Marco.
For me, very little in
the sense that, of course,
it's another language.
You had Sophia Loren.
You had De Sica, it was
another time of our lives.
So it's a beautiful
movie, but if we
have to translate it in
an opera just as it is,
it would be utterly boring.
Utterly.
So we had to detach
ourself maximum we could,
keeping what are the most
important points, of course.
But then it was really something
that we left in our back.
And for me was an
inspiration, just
like I was telling you about
Giovanni, the first scene.
The first scene in the movie
is very good, with Raf Vallone,
very sexy, very nice.
And they have this love
affair, was very small affair.
But it's the beginning
of the story.
That was very, very
important for me
in writing this Giovanni.
Because it gives to
Giovanni a different nuance.
He's not an ogre.
He's just a sexy fascist,
let's put it this way.
So in that sense, we have a
lot of influence for the movie.
But for the story, we had
to really take another path
and go away.
And I don't know if
Marco agrees with me.
MARCO TUTINO: Yes, I agree.
But the movie, for
me it was important.
Because when I
wrote the music, I
have to say that the eyes
of Sophia were in my mind.
And the character of
Michele, Rosetta and Sophia
inspired my music.
Because you know,
in the book there
is a very cold
description of facts.
I need the movie to figure in
the reality these characters.
It's important to have
a figure in front of you
when you write music.
It's very important.
Because it's a
different thing to write
an aria for a literal
imagination or a woman.
KIP CRANNA: An abstract idea.
But you knew you were writing
for Anna Caterina Antonacci,
and you had written an
opera for her before.
MARCO TUTINO: Yes, yes.
KIP CRANNA: So you
had some ideas.
MARCO TUTINO: Yes, of course.
I knew that Anna Caterina would
be the principal guest star.
And I know very well
her characteristic--
the vocal characteristic,
and her possibilities
as an actress.
And so also this knowledge
is very important to me.
KIP CRANNA: Is there
another question out there?
AUDIENCE: Yes, first of
all, from the previous guy's
question, I've never heard
of the movie before today.
And also I had the pleasure
of seeing Anna Caterina
last night.
And I'm very much
looking forward
in "Les Troyens," looking
forward to next week.
But my question is kind of
a difficult question, which
is, I've been a long-time
subscriber to San Francisco
Opera.
And over, let's
say, 30 years, I've
seen numerous premieres,
numerous new operas come up.
And most of them
have been performed
for about two or three years.
And I've never seen them again.
I've never heard of them again.
About the only
exception I can think of
is "Einstein on the
Beach," which had its 25th.
Are audiences just
not interested?
Are audiences--
like the novelty,
but don't want to support an
opera beyond its opening night?
I don't like the
fact that opera seems
to have gone to a time of
Puccini and then stopped.
And nothing past Pucinni has
become part of our repertoire.
How can we change that?
KIP CRANNA: I'll
dispute that statement.
I think we are actually
in a kind of a golden age
of American opera right now.
And although it's true
that, as in the past,
not every opera succeeds
and becomes a standard,
that is happening.
And it's happened to pieces
like "Nixon in China," which
is being done all the
time around the country.
Among the pieces that I've
been directly involved with,
the world premiers of,
"Streetcar Named Desire"
is done all the time.
We did it-- premiered
here in '98,
and we did it last summer in
our young artists program.
"Dead Man Walking"
has been performed
in more than 50 cities,
some on three continents.
AUDIENCE: I'm thrilled to
hear that both of those have
[INAUDIBLE].
KIP CRANNA: "Doctor Atomic"
fits in that category.
And Appomattox, which is Philip
Glass piece we premiered,
is going on to
other productions.
So-- but, of course, not
every piece is a winner.
And it takes a while to figure
out which ones those are.
And as Marco alluded to,
time will only tell, really,
what stays in the
repertoire, and what is only
a temporary popular piece.
NICOLA LUISOTTI: I would
like to clarify this part,
the interest what you said.
And what you said
to, because I said
I would like to refer
Italian operas, what I said,
instead of global.
Because as you said, there
are many American composers
that are very successful.
But we are missing Italian
successful composer
after Puccini, this
main world-- that can be
performed all over the world.
And the idea to perform
in another-- I mean,
to continue to the big
Italian tradition of melodies,
is, for this reason, to
give another time, space,
to new generations of
composer that are not
scared to write melodies.
Because today sounds like,
if you write a melody,
you have to be in the
jail after the last note.
And you are a bad guy, because
you have written something
that the public will love.
This is not good.
So, I think, that Marco
has written something
that-- I mean, at the
premiere, we had an evidence.
LUCA ROSSI: Yes, to go to jail.
NICOLA LUISOTTI:
We had-- no, we had
10 minutes of screaming people.
And we had 10 minutes of
standing ovation immediately
after the last note, screaming.
And when Marco went in
front of the audience,
they were screaming.
And he was embarrassed, he
became pale immediately.
He was close to faint.
Why?
Because I think
people need beauty.
That's it.
We need to go in the Yosemite
and say, oh, my god, what
beautiful Sequoias.
We don't want to see the
Sequoias like that, burned.
We want to see something
that's still alive.
And we want to just be shocked
by the natural, by the beauty.
Why not?
LUCA ROSSI: And by feelings.
NICOLA LUISOTTI: And by the
feeling, by the emotions.
We are still alive.
We are not machines.
We are human beings
need-- that need beauty.
So, thanks to Marco
Tutino to bring the beauty
to San Francisco Opera.
KIP CRANNA: Another question?
AUDIENCE: Yes, actually
this is very related
to what you just said.
But I just wanted to hear
from the composer, like.
It sounds like one of
the goals of the opera
was to make it accessible
and easier to sell tickets.
But was it very constraining
for the composer to do that?
Or, how did that feel?
KIP CRANNA: Yes, do
you feel constrained
by the goal of making an
opera that will be popular,
that the audience will enjoy?
MARCO TUTINO: No, no, no.
Absolutely, no.
I tried in all my
career to do something
that may arrive to the public.
And for me is, yes,
for me is natural.
I'm not able to
write music that is--
I know that I'm
writing only to please
the critics and some friends
KIP CRANNA: Academics.
MARCO TUTINO: Yes, and
the academic world.
I'm not able.
It's my fault. I'm not able.
So for me, it's natural.
I take the book.
I take the libretto.
I sit on the piano.
And music arrives.
It's not my responsibility.
[LAUGHTER]
MARCO TUTINO: No, absolutely.
The music arrives naturally.
So I have only to choose
in which way to put notes
and where.
But notes arrive by themselves.
I'm not a creator, I'm medium.
So, really, this
is very easy to me.
NICOLA LUISOTTI:
I have in mind, I
know you've never
thought about this.
Could you imagine
"Yesterday" by John Lennon
in dodecaphonic style?
Tell me.
If "Yesterday"
was famous today--
I like dodecaphonic style.
I am a musician.
I have studied dodecaphonic.
I have written
dodecaphonic when I
was a student of a composition.
KIP CRANNA: This is
twelve-tone serialism.
NICOLA LUISOTTI:
Yes, serialism music.
And I loved his music.
But it's my personal
opinion, because I
understand that music.
But as an audience, could
you imagine go and its now
I open my broadcast radio,
and listen to "Yesterday"
in the serial style.
[SINGING SERIAL STYLE]
Yesterday,
all my troubles
seemed so far away.
How is possible that you go
to the bed remembering that?
I think that we need to, little
bit, go back to go ahead again.
I'm not telling,
go back to go back.
Go back to the future.
Go back, and back to the future.
So, I think this is
they way that I'm
thinking to the operas.
We have to be brave, bold.
And I'm asking the composer,
go back and get music
from the movies.
Get music from [INAUDIBLE].
Do new shows.
But please, please,
write music that
will remain in the future for
the audience, for human being.
One day, we understand
through our microchips.
We are in the
right place, right?
Microchips, all sounds that
becoming from other parts
of the universe.
And that will be another day.
But still today, we love
"Yesterday" by John Lennon,
as it's written.
So, we will love also La
Ciociara by microchip Tutino
as it's written.
Believe me.
KIP CRANNA: I think we have
time for one more question.
AUDIENCE: It's a
rare privilege for us
to have access to the composer.
I wanted to hear more about
the composing process itself.
Composers come from completely
different traditions.
Some could just sit
down and write it.
Others take 15 years to
write the work of their life.
Some start from the beginning
or end, a lot of iterations.
Or you might go back to work
in some motifs, back and forth.
I wanted to hear about the
process, what made this work so
beautifully in the end.
I'd like to hear more
about the secrets,
if you're comfortable sharing.
KIP CRANNA: So, Marco, about
your compositional process.
Do you wait for
the words before--
MARCO TUTINO: My
composition, oh.
Well, the truth is that--
NICOLA LUISOTTI:
Don't tell the secret!
MARCO TUTINO: No.
No, it's possible.
I try to explain.
When I write music, when I
finish to write music, and also
in this case of this
score, believe me
I completely forget all.
I don't remember.
I don't know why.
And I don't know in which
way I was able to write this.
It's impossible
for me to remember.
It's a tragedy,
because every time
that I have to start again
to write-- For me, I think,
but I'm not able.
It is absolutely
impossible to write music.
It's very difficult. Because
you have to control a lot.
You have to control rhythm,
harmony, melodies, structures.
Impossible.
For me, it's impossible to--
So, I simply sit down at
the piano, as I told before.
And I open a door.
I really open a door.
And there are days in which
this door remains closed,
and this day it's better to go
to take a walk, or to sleep,
or to whatever you want.
But there are days in which the
door open, and a river comes.
And I don't know.
I trust in this.
I have to put the river in the
right way in [SPEAKING ITALIAN]
But--
KIP CRANNA: [INAUDIBLE].
MARCO TUTINO: Oh, wonderful,
the same in Italy.
KIP CRANNA: Very sexy.
Yes.
MARCO TUTINO: I put
the river in his bed.
And I tried the
river done comes out.
But it's all.
The river is not my
responsibility, as I told.
So, I really can't say, what
are my process of composition.
Because if a composer has
very present to himself,
which are the technique
in which he wrote,
I think that is not good.
It's not good, because
while you are writing,
you put this consciousness
in this score.
And if the publics
feel that you are
thinking about your
techniques, you're finished.
So you have to
absolutely forget,
don't remember everything.
AUDIENCE: This is Google.
I have to ask this
follow-up question.
Do you do your composition
and orchestration by hand,
or do you use software?
MARCO TUTINO: I compose at the
piano with a very technological
instrument that is a pencil.
A pen and--
LUCA ROSSI: A sheet of paper.
MARCO TUTINO: Yes, a sheet of
paper, white, with five lines.
It's a very clever
system, I observe.
But when I finish this
first fixing of ideas,
I have to put in
the computer, yes.
Because in this way, I
can hear, more or less,
what I have just done.
And I use Finale, like,
the software is Finale.
And I use Apple,
a wonderful iMac.
NICOLA LUISOTTI: And he was
sending to me the score.
Every time he was
writing a scene,
he was sending to me the score.
I was, of course, hearing
the music by the program.
But also, of course,
reading in another very
modern and technological
instrument.
This is the piano.
I was putting my piano.
I was playing with my
technological hands.
And that worked perfectly.
And all the time, he was
sending me the music,
he said, Nicola, it's
not me that is writing.
It's not me.
He was like, it was beautiful
the process of composition.
Because he don't
remember, but I remember.
Because I followed for two
years, every single passage
of this.
One day in my bio
I will write that.
KIP CRANNA: I think we're
at the end of our time.
But before we conclude, I
do want to remind people
that San Francisco
Opera will be doing
one of its free,
annual simulcasts
at AT&T Park on Saturday,
July 3-- Friday, sorry,
it's a Friday.
Friday, July 3, at 7:30.
It's free.
You can sign up by just
going to SFOpera.com
and give us your email address.
And that'll get you
early admission.
And you can come and
sit anywhere you like,
and picnic if you like.
It's opera and garlic fries,
what could be better than that?
Thank you all for doing
this, my fellow panelists.
And thank you, Google,
for inviting us.
It's been a pleasure.
NICOLA LUISOTTI: Thank you.
MARCO TUTINO: Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]